hi everyone and today we have the iphone
se 2022 version we have the 256 gigabyte
model down here as you can see right
there and as you can see down here it is
the iphone sc we got it early thanks
again apple and this one obviously runs
the same chip as the iphone 13 the a15
bionic chip and this thing is really
small so this is like kind of it can
barely fit the size of my hand and we
have the iphone 13 mini over here which
is slightly smaller than the iphone se
as you can see down here the s is a
little longer and a little wider as well
compared to the 13 mini and we have the
13 pro here as well just so you guys can
see the difference so 13 pro
and the iphone sc yeah this the 13 pro
is obviously a lot bigger
like definitely
so with all these games claire will be
playing gangshin because i'm quite weak
stars i haven't reached in the zuma yet
so she'll be playing that and i'll be
playing the rest so let's just jump into
the game hi it's clara today we are here
with the iphone se 2022 and i'll be
playing genji but first let's check the
temperature of the iphone
okay so we're starting with 26.7 degrees
celsius let's enter kimchi
real first
okay
okay so now we're in genji let's check
our graphic settings
okay
so
we're now going to set everything on
high ho
yo oh
okay 60 frames per second
and we should be good to go
yahoo
yes okay so looking around the scenery
in genjen we see that everything is in
full render
and there's so much detail to our
characters
okay so today we'll be fighting the
thunder manifestation with this morgana
team let's go
[Applause]
okay
diana first
[Music]
[Applause]
so far i have not seen any frame rate
drops
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
no frame rate drop so far
and i am dying in hd quality
yoho
oh no
[Music]
[Applause]
and we're done
so after a round of playing with the
thunder manifestation let's check how
the phone is doing
[Music]
so right now it's at 33.4 degrees
celsius let's check the other corner
[Music]
okay so it's about 30 degrees
and it's a slight difference from just
now
that's the check
so 31
and
corners
also 31
okay so after a bit of gameplay the
average temperature of the iphone sc is
about 31 degrees and i think compared to
my own iphone the iphone 13 it's running
pretty well everything is being animated
smoothly so if you're looking for a
budget iphone to run your graphic
intensive games like gen xin on you
might want to invest in the iphone se
2022
okay so we're in the settings right now
and let's just see we have
alright ultra hd ultra high frame rate
we have
water reflectors enabled and the early
things off
shadows are enabled brightness all right
so let's just restart the game so that
the changes can take effect
let me just do that real quick
all right we have restarted the game so
let's just get into it
and before that let's just check the
temperature real quick
about 31.3
about 30.8
yep
so it's about 31 degrees celsius average
so let's just see how it turns out at
the end of the game or at least until i
die
but so far i know things are looking
very smooth animations are great no
frame drops whatsoever so far
oh my god the king of mine i'm gonna
build this guy
no
yeah anyway i kind of agree that you
know
the iphone se should be a little bigger
oh okay
it's right there
become one
oh no
something good
i'm gonna give you guys
and he's done
oh man i'm down oh god damn it okay
great it's all game
come on man help me out come on blue
i'm done
beautiful
all right first game wasn't that great
but let's just try one more just for
good measure
and so far
[Applause]
ah 32.2 degrees not much of a difference
to be honest
yeah
as someone with big hands right this
thing is uh
it's a little bit of a challenge to play
with because it's so small just look at
that again right and the fact that this
phone handles as much power with the a15
bionic chip that the iphone 13 has you
know it's it's a pretty good deal
okay we're going to drop
oh
how fun
very fun
will be
fine come on come on come on pick it up
come and pick it up yeah oh boy oh gosh
okay
cool cool cool
oh damn it gosh
oh
okay fine fine i know i suck okay
yeah but so far you know
fassi handles it pretty well i haven't
noticed any frame drops whatever so far
so you know
if this thing can handle ganshin you can
definitely handle pubg mobile oh never
mind so if this is the candle ganshin
it can handle anything one
yeah not much of a difference this thing
is hanging pretty well
maybe like a slight
120 degrees difference but
not bad so far not bad and the other
thing about the iphone se is that it
brings back the home button so if you
want to close apps just go to double tap
here and just whoop and that's it
so after pubg let's just go down the
line this way with apex being the last
let's just go with mobile legends
not again
alright since i've signed in let's play
some mobile legends
as i said pretty quick boot up
all right now that we're here let's go
to the graphics report
and yeah shadow's on creep hp's on
everything's on
graphics is on the highest refresh rate
is high
everything
is on high right now so let's just get
into classic
[Music]
alright let's
hope for the best with this one
welcome to mobile legend
i agree with as always let's just
keep this rolling
so yeah let's just see what the iphone
se can do i mean so far it looks pretty
good you know graphics is great
animations are very smooth
oh okay never mind those scary
come on
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
all right since we got our first kill
let's just do a quick temperature check
32.8
very slight difference from just now oh
34 in some areas
yeah baseline is about 34 degrees-ish
baselines right now is about 34 degrees
celsius it's not that hard
it still feels pretty cool in my hand so
no complaints just yet
now it doesn't like those scary monsters
legendary
free defeat guy
nice
so yeah
all right temperature check at the end
of the game
let's just see
it's still about 34.4 34.1 yeah average
34 degrees you know this thing is going
fine it doesn't feel toasty in my hand
at all
so let's just move on to the next game
then so with mobile legends out of the
way let's just do a quick temperature
check again we are back at 39.7 29.5
around there
so let's say to say 839 degrees celsius
is the average so let's let's go to call
of duty real quick
[Music]
i'd say the reason why it's taking a bit
more to load up is because you know call
of duty mobile has a lot of assets going
on so
that's probably why but other than that
it's pretty quick still
come on just a little bit more
there we go
all right
let's set things
okay
all right very high frame rate is at
max now but i think we need to restart
the game so that it can take effect
and
for multiplayer
anti-aliasing is on con oh contain
everything on this let's just turn
everything on
and let's just restart the game so that
the changes can take effect
let's just jump into a game
let's go
but yeah as you saw just now you know
the graphics are the main page and
everything looks really great and yeah
my gun looks amazing
oh okay never mind but you know
whatever
right now but
enemy contact
no never mind
yeah no frame rate drops nothing it's
running real smooth
there really isn't a lot to continue
again again
things but it's not stopping me yet
come on
oh come on
wow okay
so yeah with that done let's just give
it a real quick temperature check
32.8 33.3
yeah i'd say it's about 32 degrees
celsius
this phone is really handling the game
really well
nothing to complain about and with that
let's move on to apex legends legends
obviously you know this just came out so
there may be optimization issues
but you know
give it some time
if you have what it takes
to become an apex legend
cement your place in history
oh okay that was fast
all right let's get into the game
relatively quick boot up compared to
call of duty
and let's just do a real quick baseline
for this 33
[Applause]
ah it's safe to say 29 degrees
yep all right display set things okay
so
let's just go with
extreme let's go uh
high apparently i can't go to the ultra
all right let's just do that let's just
push it to its limits
right and adaptive smoothing
dynamic shadows something listening
character halo no why not right
and then
okay and i did the smoothing
let's just go
let's restart the game so that the
changes can take effect
and yes i'll be playing it quite a bit
over the weekend
i mean obviously it kind of compared to
the pc version but you know it is what
it is
let's do this
all right we're dropping off am i the
gym master
and i'll just try to treat someone else
let's go over here
train yard is the best place for loot
but okay actually not really but you
know it does the job as you can see
everything out in front like this
very nice
come on
let's just get out of here real quick
we got what we needed
oh
[Music]
oh come on
yeah to talk about the graphics a little
bit you know the sun's rays are hitting
out the flat line everything within this
area looks really good
obviously when it's far off it looks
kind of meh
but you know
it works
all right so now while things are still
pretty chill let's just do a quick
temperature check
wow
okay
quite a big jump from the 29 we saw
earlier on or at least from our baseline
but you know what
this phone doesn't feel that hard at all
it's not it's not even toasty
like it's a little one
but it's nothing we should be concerned
about
or rather there's nothing to be
concerned about
oh yes finally we gotta
fight and i'm out there with him great
beautiful
let's finish him off
oh okay you won
wow wow okay not bad
okay
so now that's done let's just do a final
temperature check
35.7 yeah it kind of went down a little
bit
all right it's safe to say that you know
the average right now is about 36
degrees celsius but you know
yeah the sc can handle a lot of games
really well i mean like things it does
have the power iphone 13 so
there's really not much you can say
about it but the main thing is that you
know it's just really small
in my hands and like you know it's a bit
uncomfortable so so if you're someone
who has big hands like myself i'd rather
you get an iphone 13 and iphone 13 pro
or even better if you can afford an
iphone 13 pro max because the iphone sc
because the iphone sc you know it packs
a lot of punch you know
and because i the iphone sc you know it
packs a lot of punch for such a small
package but that's the problem it's it's
a little too small for me but if you're
someone with smaller hands or you know
just normal sized hands i guess if
that's a thing you would find that this
phone will fit all your gaming needs
so
yeah that pretty much wraps up the video
and yeah after playing like five games
in the last two hours
you're at about
how much is it again we're about 70 so
obviously this phone handles itself
pretty well so if you're playing the
game on the go this you will know this
phone is reliable
so yeah that's all we have for the
iphone se leave a comment down below and
if you have any questions about the
phone you can ask them and we'll get to
you as best we can
do not forget to follow us on all of our
socials remember to like and subscribe
to us we have a lot of content coming to
you
and with that this is zinio signing off
and i'll see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you